à saint claude il y à ce relief toujours
intimidant mais en ce moment c'est
surtout l'économie qui donnent le
vertige aux habitants le principal
employeur privé de la ville
mbf et dans des routes plus de patron
depuis deux mois
raphaël elle est photographe indépendant
il viens ici régulièrement photographe
s'est pas ok je suis pote on ma liste
mais elle fonctionne dans un premier
temps jean roger je fais des images
l'essai de ce sens j'essaie de ressentir
mais en même temps c'est même pas moi
qui sent c'est mon appareil photo
280 salariés à l'abandon qui continue à
entretenir le site
les salaires sont versés par la région
par l'état mais pour combien de temps
tous ne vivent pas à la même au même
niveau cette histoire y en a qui sont
pleins d'énergie vont se battre et chic
qui sont en lutte qu'ils sont et puis
d'autres qui sont déprimés par deux mois
de grève et que et que qui sont épuisés
pour photographier les enfants les
familles s'est photographiée aussi des
gens c'est de l'humain quoi passer et ne
sais pas où vous les failles et le
capitalisme ces choses
renault préfère aller faire réaliser ces
pièces là où les mains de la main
d'oeuvre est moins chère
la manoeuvre aller ici c'est ces gens là
par mois je
topick c'est un projet chaque assemblée
générale pousse un peu plus les ouvriers
à faire un choix
plusieurs repreneurs ont jeté l'épongé
et voilà que l'idée d'une coopérative
ouvrière une scop sème le trouble dans
les esprits des critères moi c'était
soit je vais pas en faire partie je veux
bien quoi
dans le centre ville de saint-claude un
immeuble incarne l'idéal des
coopérateurs la maison du peuple
appelée aussi la fraternelle le bâtiment
garde la mémoire des ouvriers pipier des
premier metaleux venus d'italie au début
1900 c'est une terre d'émigration fait 5
tonnes et j'aime bien cette idée aussi
que ce soit un des ouvriers d'origine le
turc
enfin étrangères
marocaine
l' ancien qui sont qui sans ce fameux
comptoir antoine n'est ni ma foi c'est
eux les comptoirs en fait ici à 5 tonnes
et qui essayent de maintenir
voilà la ville aussi
ce qui compte quand même pour moi c'est
d'essayer de relier de comprendre où on
en est aujourd'hui par à la lumière du
passé quoi
retour à l'usiné dans les ateliers un
stock d'arbres à cames des carter pour
l'automobile et des lingots d'aluminium
un trésor de guerre estimé à plus d'un
million et demi d'euros
l'aluminium faut ça va c'est pas que la
voiture c'est celle et rincez les avions
c'est c'est les chariots élévateurs et
des robots c'est ça la l'aluminium donc
c'est donc un moyen de trouver je pense
y aurait moyen de trouver des panneaux
m2 et partenariats pour vraiment pour
faire repartir la boîte ça c'est sûr je
vous promets rien à quelques jours d'un
rendez vous capital devant le tribunal
administratif
un repreneur sort du bois passage obligé
devant les salariés une option
différente de la scop
moi j'ai dépôt tête
comme j'ai dit c'est oui ou non key par
contre nous si c'est oui on ira jusqu'au
bout
this et non pas ça non moi j'ai le
ramener en erreur j'essaye toutes les
possibilités comme moi j'accompagne
j'espère de tout coeur que ces gens là
vont pouvoir continuer à travailler quoi
en attendant les fours continue de
ronronner les salariés surveille
l'aluminium comme le lait sur le feu
dans l'emploi les tanks puisque a coupé
l'alimentation le métal refroidirait
sophie jaurès le jour où ces menaces et
âme
bah ça veut dire que l'usiné l'infini et
les meurtres
après 70 jours de grève qui détient la
réponse
saint-claude attend en équilibre au bord
du précipice
[Musique]